[Music]
this week we got hotpot Ilan toque Oh
Pete's tattoos oh he's a temp eat a
pizza or the ugh pizza we're gonna find
out and guess who's gonna tell you oh
yeah
slow down thank you Dan all right I like
to anticipate this is an interrupting
TIFF okay this is Wiggins franchise all
right first off what kind of pizza the
first story there's this woman who went
to this hotpot place and she found
let me guess in China yeah really
oh I saw this one you should found a rat
damn it I wanted them to find out oh my
man oh they found a rat in the broth
yeah this isn't China we probably would
have guessed worse okay so that's that's
right that was fine quick question good
question for all of you guys if you guys
had the most delicious hotpot [ __ ] no
bars and then you find the rat
afterwards would you guys continue
throwing a rats into up I would throw
rats into a constant one yet I mean the
water is boiling right I said my new
favorite is you can answer depends on
what kind of rat we're talking about
because you can see how disgusting this
is it looks pretty nuts you ready
actually I had Korean barbeque in in my
lettuce in my last it was a fly
no one cares a barbecued no I mean it
was just like soaked up and dead and
then I just put it to the side and I
kept eating yeah my man no you know when
I can hit a fly I feel very proud of
myself
Thank You Nikki I want to show you those
of my boxes I feel that my bossing has
been paying off on my after month we got
the stories out what you're gonna do
about it
I finally saw it first and I wanna do it
again
you like Emma Spanish no you have to buy
burritos and then get to keep those
races I'm pretty attacks me alright so
first she's gonna show the restaurant
and then you'll see the rest I love the
music hmm
that's my alma mater centuries later
kinda looks fake it does look fake it
looks like Chucky Cheese now it looks
like it's supposed to be a part of the
meal don't give it away in case you
understood I didn't dapples accent was
crazy was she like oh [ __ ] this is Thai
I didn't pay for this and I said no meat
but I'd end up giving me for free all
right so this woman she was eating with
their friends right and then she found
this rat so then they brought it up to
the restaurant owner and then that's
when the restaurant owner offered the
group a one-time compensation of five
thousand yuan which is about seven
hundred and twenty eight dollars that's
a lot of money and they refused to
accept the amount because one of them
like the woman found it she was pregnant
and so she was like oh no she's like I
need to undergo some medical check-ups
to make sure that my baby is okay and
then that's when the owner he upped his
price to 20 thousand yuan which is about
two thousand nine hundred for her to get
an abortion that escalated like a
gonna say $2,000 to get a medical
check-up no oh don't worry okay I gave
it mm you can carry your baby
the Chinese logic is crazy for your
absolute silence two grand
yeah that's incredible right abortion
fee no worry Boston on me okay don't
please go back I don't even surprised
that he decided to compensate that
[ __ ] much that's very generous for
Chinese I was on his side even in the US
I took he went there I love that it's no
good for a Chinese person that Blair
why'd you throw a rat in the soup I know
you brought that rat in don't try to
sabotage me it would be the customers
fault you know there are a lot of people
that do that though they bring like
[ __ ] like beans in a ziploc bag and
then they try to scan the place me and
Nikki we used to have a favorite sushi
place and then this we used to go all
the time and then this couple one time
they were upset because they found a
hair in their sushi and the people
didn't believe her and they think we
threw them out like every year yeah that
was really poorly yeah like really
meaning they were rude they brought the
manager on he was yelling at her - yeah
but that's Japanese though yeah yeah
yeah no I know but I just love the tiny
sushi changes Japanese but like yeah
they were the waitress was Blamey
hundred percent and then the manager
then the manager like double like was
young even like the waitress was Chinese
Japanese rested the hair match any other
workers oh I didn't look at the girls
food it just was weird because it was
causing a scene like because the guests
seemed really polite they were like hey
we just I just want to we just don't
want this meal you know like we found a
heron and we just don't want it and
she's like no like you have to have like
it no we didn't do that yeah yeah we
didn't you were gonna pay you will pay
who's like that is like that
never going back there we used to love
that place sure those are those our
first date oh man and it wasn't even
your meal is just the fact that they
handle it yes that's the way that they
were handling it cuz we saw from
beginning to end what an awesome first
date to witness drama like that no no no
that was way later that was our first
date spot that's what we used to go
there a lot
I thought that's how you guys bonded we
bonded over this lady over this terrible
time so you both felt about it yeah yeah
so then this hot hot spot they sort of
couple or that the entire group they
ended up reporting it to Bureau and then
so they came and they checked out the
business license a catering service
permit and the health safety certificate
are all legal and they were they had an
entire sanitary standards inspection and
they passed other than that without the
rock in it other than water that would
accumulate on the ground in the
processing area at certain times that's
the only that they mentioned but they
the bureau did end up temporarily
suspending the operations just for
further inspection to make sure like how
did this wreck get in here what about
his bargaining point of here's 2000 in
line for the abortion I don't know I
think they just said they've just
reported it but they won't even check it
just get it aborted
that's [ __ ] queer despot he made an
offer she didn't have to take the offer
I think it was kind of quiet
the logic is just so random that is or
maybe they were like fighting and then
that's just like fighting words yeah
I'll give you 2 grand just have it
abortion you know like that makes sense
that's true
instead of like I really wish it's the
other side though like here serious I
have a good idea you don't have to go to
the doctor I want no problem yeah do it
again
you yard
all right bride next story you guys
heard my Elon Musk
smoked on John Joe Rogan the horror
podcast the [ __ ] I didn't get to watch
the whole thing I used to be a huge fan
of Elon Musk and then I saw him smoke on
Joe Rogan and I was like never again
didn't you shatter all your morals and
expectations everything that's why I
can't prove the way the media's been
playing this that wait is it it he lands
out of control I'm like he smoked on Joe
Rogan that's what you do want Joe Rove I
thought the controversy was more that he
drug tested his employees he it for
marijuana that was the controversy all I
see is being a hypocrite because he
won't hire people if they have if they
fail of marijuana drug test but when one
of those drug test though cuz it could
be dated right like if it was yeah when
marijuana was hella illegal totally he
just wants to catch people that break
the law not necessarily catch marijuana
smokers and then now if it's more
legalized to be different it depends
what I see because I controversy what
I've seen though is like Musk out of
control the keys over the deep end all
this [ __ ] that's what I've seen that's
just like dude what like I love this era
right now and how we're treating weed
because that's already how I've been
feeling since I was 13 and I'm also like
looking at my parents like just watch
one day weed is gonna be just like
alcohol it's gonna be fine and they
treated weed like it was crack yeah
that's I remember being growing up in
like the DARE program and stuff and it
was like oh don't miss Gryce don't smoke
do it's a gateway drug brother brave man
and then I and then I remember going
home crying cuz I thought people were
gonna bully me into doing their drugs
because that's how they make you seem
like they they sit around you and they
be like you better do these drugs man
you better do this expensive thing that
I spent a lot of money on hey you want
to do coke why not and then they put if
you look at knife to your throat you
better do this [ __ ] seven or norcold
yeah college it was so scared of bullies
doing that to be why would anybody want
to share their [ __ ] drugs the only
sheriff drugs with your friends was a
cos hell of money yeah you don't share
with other people that have drugs so you
guys could have drugs together yeah
train you is I never one time in my life
experienced that moment of like hey you
want to try the thing like never know if
I had a bag of weed I'm like get your
[ __ ] filthy hands away because you
guys are all three loaders that's what I
was like if anything just cool people my
apartment building and now are like hey
you want smoke I know my arms no thank
you though you know what I get it more
from alcoholics
why don't you honestly anyone that
doesn't drink or anyone doesn't drink
coffee all so I'm like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you know Steve doesn't
drink coffee I'm like I just don't
[ __ ] understand him
crackheads are the opposite because they
want to themselves always something
you're settling on smoking it's pretty
gay that's a pretty good hit really you
didn't inhale at all oh really
that's dope that means we just puffs it
out yeah okay so it's like posh he
doesn't notice month don't worry yeah I
think I tried one once
[Laughter]
just stop go down 9% what it was like in
this moment that's the stupidest [ __ ]
I've ever heard tobacco and marijuana in
there it's what they mixed it yeah he
didn't inhale
no he just puffed it and blew it out
that's the screenshot everywhere yeah
that's his reshot mosque out of control
he's lost his [ __ ] mind doing there's
a pretty cool mural of him too like
someone just painted up a mirror of that
last oh that's dope that makes another
badass
tougher and they should also have like a
bubble coming out of the mural that's
like talking about aliens
juvenilia if you don't smoke though he
probably got high because like that room
just being hotbox and then like oh yeah
I've been taking a puff and that's a
pretty fat joint like an article that
said that you can't get a contact high
unless you're in a very very horrible
that's not true that can't be that's not
sure I've gotten contact I saw many
times I'm so sensitive to pot yeah and I
don't want to be high I'm always the one
that's like no not me and I try to get
away from it because I start getting
paranoid as [ __ ] and my heart just like
it's a very clear difference from sober
to being like hi and it just starts
racing and then I just think like I'm
dying and like every possible reason
that I'm dying when I'm high I just
swear to God that I'm not high the whole
time
and that's how I know I'm hot I'm like
no no I'm not high I'm really and then
he's like but I'm not weird right yeah
I'm like hell but I'm being completely
normal right it's like dude you're
[ __ ] high what what a normal what
yeah why I'm not weird it's amazing I
know and I'm I everyone else I keep
telling myself I am high but yeah so 9
percent because everyone freaked out
chorus why go to executives quit - I
can't believe you smoked weed Elan yeah
you're the devil well then the whole
thing is like I guess lately they
they're big problems of the company so
this is just like the last straw like
now you're smoking weed on me to bid
what I like about you on those he's so
human yeah like he what he's doing is so
awesome - cuz he's going against the car
industry's going against like fossil
fuels and all that [ __ ] and he's very
revolutionary but he's also like a CEO
that's normalized like he smokes weed he
he says whatever he wants it's like so
he can he can print it ha you could
print it hot and it sells out right away
cuz no one gives a [ __ ] about the Hat
they just got a rep him cuz I so dope I
got the turn and the blue and not a blue
not flame torch
not flamethrower dude I think that
they're trying to destroy him because he
is the only absolute counter voice
against AI I agree and I think that
that's the plan yeah I also just don't
understand why it's blowing up over
something that's a legal substance like
if it was federally illegal but he's in
California yes but it still has a stigma
of the propaganda that was created in
the passengers a lot of people still
alive today that are still brainwashed
from that old-time plane crazy is that
they don't understand that people at
that level now they're not doing weed I
mean they probably do do weed but
they're [ __ ] doing cocaine and some
other crazier [ __ ] but they're just not
publicizing it and they're just gonna
act like all offended that like Elon yes
Steve Jobs cydia doesn't trust anyone
that didn't do LSD we could be buddies
that's a good time we forget about that
huh damn I didn't do no LSD you do some
LSD I know and I'm named after Steve
Jobs I should do it just because of that
I think it's different when you're older
and you do it I haven't done it this day
and age what's different I imagine just
like being young and not being so
self-aware you probably have a very
different trip than you are like when
you were more aware of yourself you have
responsibilities yeah cuz like I
remember like I mean when I was like 14
I would smoke weed walk outside go
skating whatever and then everything was
fun but now I'm like super paranoid
that's flipped for me it's philosophy
yeah because I was so paranoid that I
didn't want anyone going back to my
parents and like telling on me cuz I was
booked but now I'm like why control on
my [ __ ] you know like with the
if I get fine I mean I can get in
trouble with do smoke time yeah yeah
it's it's not like I'm afraid of
anything it's just a like point it's
like pointless like I'm not I don't know
what I'm afraid of
so I'm like like we'll be walking around
in Vegas and stuff and I'm just like mmm
there's no real threat yeah yeah yeah
I'm just kind of like I don't feel safe
yeah yeah yeah fine like that that yeah
like you can't he's not a scary person
yeah or police or you try to talk me
down they'll be like hey everything's
good yes
oh but like I just feel like something
like I'm gonna die yeah but if I'm in a
room and we're just watching [ __ ]
together it's totally fine yeah yeah
I could watch cartoons with them Allah
follow me turn down and rap music turned
up and then I thought being I've always
wanted to do that it's all funny
I've always wanted to smoke weed and
watch like like wicked Morty or
something like the mean is I turn the
volume down and then turn the rap music
up and it looks like they're rapping but
you know what's up next Nikki what's up
there pizza story musician yes Wow so
Domino's goes crisp Russian Domino's
they and Russian Domino's wait the pizza
place Domino's Pizza is the end bad
people in Russia is the end back we're
moving on so they announced that if
whoever gets a tattoo there's a statue
in front of it like a [ __ ] old Lenin
statue who's interrupting - sorry I
should picture what Bart said the
reverse ok yeah la boca oh sorry hmm so
dominoes they announce that whoever gets
a tattoo of their logo they will get
10,000 free pizzas which is for a
hundred years you can get 100 pizzas
what if you get a tattoo if you guys had
to does it have to be of something
specific oh oh yeah so it's called their
Domino's forever campaign on social
media and so they're pretty much
offering free pizza for your whole life
and so pretty good immediately yeah just
get it immediately started getting on
then so they specified that it has to be
somewhere visible oh okay
so then everyone just started posting
photos of all like wow
in all these places while they're losing
so much pizza the one last free [ __ ] man
dude watch Tom Rose goes out of business
because of this and now everyone has
these tattoos yeah we can't even afford
the beat some of those are cool yeah
yeah I like the one with the Domino on
the pizza that was I like the black and
white Domino's Fanta remember the Domino
character he was like a rabbit man yeah
he's weird
no that's time you had like a red suit
on oh yeah of course I remember him
doing those narrow or I forgot but I
miss him you there was a game yeah yeah
the domino game Oh Mac tonight is still
my favorite the moon yeah the crescent
moon oh oh yeah yeah so then they they
posted this they're like okay just to
clarify cause people like they got so
many submissions like it has to be
somewhere visible damn know who's on
your visible plate so they got in there
was wrong and it didn't even qualify
like they got another but sheet so then
they ended up getting way too many
participants and then they started
saying like listen we're just gonna do
this for the first 350 participant
funkdoc so so then they immediately was
like okay stop stop submitting stop
getting to do like we've got our 350
like no more but the live deal would be
uploading some photos cuz they did a
deadline they're like by 12 o'clock
today like no more and then so some
people they uploaded it after the
deadline and they were still nice enough
they would comment on those photos and
be like hey all right so we're gonna
send you a DM though that's nice of that
ever underestimate the human need for
free [ __ ] now every 7-eleven when you go
to 7-eleven you get a free slurpie Day
ring but July 11th dude it's [ __ ]
great it's like everyone's park for an
ariana grande concert yeah trying to get
into the 7-eleven is like nuts and I'm
like dude these things are a dollar
they're one dollar like why is it like
what about yesterday
why were you but like people just want
the free thing I remember Pancake Day
and IHOP and oh yeah
do that she was insane dude it was like
Lynyrd Skynyrd was playing big they give
away free yeah yeah take your day just
pancake I think that thing was surprised
from one pancake it's all-you-can-eat
look like the Russian Domino's
certificate is their backwards and
anywhere for Bart right there there you
go yes Burt it's just printed backwards
for me yeah it is it just printed on
paper is lemonade like laminated I feel
like people could reproduce that
probably yeah but there's probably a
certification number on there there
probably is because there are things
that are blurred out but so like how
does the person working at Domino's know
whether you're the right person for that
number they have the certification
number yeah but how do they know there's
the name and the certification number
and they type it in probably I love free
[ __ ] I love free [ __ ] like these kind of
games are really fun because it turns
into like a little Easter Egg yeah like
something let me ask you guys this
asking let's say all of us right we all
were like we love Domino's we're gonna
get Domino's Pizza we all get the
tattoos we all get this deal we have
that one friend that didn't get the
tattoos do we do we go [ __ ] you
don't get the tattoo you're not gonna
feel odd off any of our pizza yeah yeah
preload the free pizza or are you guys
are you guys nice to then go even though
you didn't get the tattoo and join us
here's a free pizza I think it depends
for me like on if it's your wife or not
because if we all got free pizza that's
a [ __ ] lot of pizza it's almost
unnecessary a group plan and see like
what one person gets McDonald's one
person gets Domino's like we all got to
do every single package or no so if
she's not getting to get DiGiorno just
give me a journal on our [ __ ] chest
right here well it's got to be like
different like foods like burgers
oh I get tummy retort yeah hell yeah
that's a lot where would you put that
tattoo cuz you could get like a journal
okay
target she loves target would you get it
right here please don't get it on your
face
[Music]